[Music]
president biden dodging the media just a
few moments ago on the nightmare he
created in afghanistan
instead the president's sitting down
with abc and claims he has no regrets on
how things unfolded
we've all seen the pictures we've seen
those hundreds of people packed into a
c-17 we've seen
afghans fall
four days ago five days ago what did you
think when you first saw those pictures
well i thought was weird we have to gain
control of this we have to move this
more quickly
we have to move in a way in which we can
take control that airport
and we did
so you don't think this could have been
handled this actually could have been
handled better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that there
we're going to go back in hindsight and
look but the idea that somehow
there's a way to have gotten out without
chaos ensuing i don't know how that
happens and while biden says that
americans can't get out of afghanistan
dubai administration says it wants to
get everybody out but can't guarantee
the safety of people trying to get to
the kabul airport because the taliban
controls all the checkpoints
that comes as we get new horrific images
of the terror group's brutality you were
warning what we're about to show you is
tough to look at
people being beaten bloodied in the
streets
including women and children
and people fleeing after gunshots broke
out when the taliban just shot into a
crowd
trying to break up a protest
so i was shocked dana that
he didn't take questions instead went to
a former clinton guy george
stephanopoulos and then he said he
couldn't have
done it any better
yeah i thought i found the president's
speech strange i i understand covet is
an important topic um but i do think
that there was a discordant note
happening here he has done this
interview with george stephanopoulos
well we have more of that for you it's
good you'll see it in full but really i
don't think that he changed anything
that he said from sunday and also when
he said that the horrific images from
the airport were i loved like four or
five days ago man come on man i was just
like two days ago and actually it was up
until recently it was still happening
there was also this big disconnect so
he's saying that nothing could have been
different but then you look in the media
and what do you see um well it is um
without sourcing anonymous sources but
it's clear that general milley wants to
make clear that he advocated for keeping
2 500 troops
secretary austin said he told the
president that full withdrawal could
lead to instability yeah the
intelligence community had they've been
warning biden for months and actually
that wasn't even classified you could
have read that on the front page of any
national newspaper we all read it we all
we all knew um and then you had the
secretary of state and the national
security advisor making it clear that
they warned about potential taliban
attacks on u.s diplomats and allies so i
felt it was discordant
it is not enough now the general and the
uh and the secretary of defense today
they indicated that they have a better
control over it but it was strange is
that i watched the state department
briefing right before that and it
sounded like the taliban was not
allowing people through and then we just
have our own reporting
and that is people that actually now
they have cell phones and they can call
and they're telling their uh people that
they know in the united states saying i
can't get out let's listen to the
secretary of defense lloyd austin today
explain what he thinks he's able to do
in afghanistan run it i would draw a
distinction bar between extracting
uh
someone in an in extremist condition or
a circumstance versus going out and
collecting up large numbers of uh of
american citizens we don't have the
capability to go out and collect up
large numbers of
of people so geraldo the secretary of
defense united states of america says
they don't have the capability
to bring americans home from a war zone
unless they themselves get to the
airport which by the way the taliban
controls
can i just say something about the
president's ill-timed speech it was it
was pitiful it was pathetic and you know
i try to give him
every every due respect i he's the
president united states i think he's a
nice person
what the hell that covet speech had to
do with the price of beans in america i
don't know and he delivered it as if
someone said here's a good idea i want
you to speak about the covet booster and
take their minds off what they're seeing
on the tv news it was really so what the
hell
uh did some adviser tell him and then he
was blinking and uh missing words and uh
i thought it was really really really
really discordant in terms of what uh
general milly and and secretary austin
were saying
you know i think that they
understand now that they are at the
fulcrum of history they were in charge
when something happened a debacle
occurred that will resonate for
generations and they were the people
there in charge
for them
i i think it's a lot of cover your ass
going on right now i think there's a lot
of scrambling going on in dc i think
there is an understanding of the
monumental nature of this uh of this
screw-up
me
i look back i i go back to the bagram
thing you know i spent so much time
about it i a quick story i remember
being about in bagram where a gi a big
strapping six foot five gi uh
had all these tubes in him at the bagram
uh hospital which was state of the art
one of the best in the world and he had
no head and they were keeping them alive
i i i know bagram bagra the wendy's and
mcdonald's and that this and that why
the world they did not keep bagram
airfield with its two landing strips
with its secure perimeter with its uh
its track record of being impregnable
from the soviet time because it was the
russians that built it and trade that
for kabul international airport which is
chaotic and a mess and the best of times
and now this whole idea of the taliban
not letting people through to the
airport that's where the rubber meets
the road if the taliban expects to be a
member of the family of nations if they
expect credit if they expect
international aid if they expect
membership in any of these international
organizations they better damn let these
people free they should let they have to
let these people get to the airport
where
our our our
logistical uh
the army and so forth is now up to
muster and can evacuate five to nine
thousand a day so now the taliban
basically travel agents right you have
to say hey muhammad you know i'd like to
get to the kabul international at four
o'clock what do i need to do to get
there we're relying on the taliban
to get out of the country because of joe
biden's failure let's make that clear
and there are tens of thousands of
afghan
uh allies of ours that are not just
around kabul that are in the south and
the east as well so americans are
stranded in a nation now run by
barbarians
and i i just want to pick up on one
thing um and i'll be brief uh geraldo
that in um millie and austin's briefing
they said our order was to protect the
embassy we had to collapse bagram
because it exceeded our military forces
so they're beginning to point the finger
at
president biden quite frankly
you use the word pitiful well
about biden that is something that is
worthy of our pity he is not worthy of
anything he is a failure in both deed
and now were to get up in front of the
american people and say nothing about
the americans and allies stranded in
afghanistan and the disaster that
unfolds in front of our faces there's a
reason
why the people who knew joe biden best
kept him at arm's length obama and all
of the big d cronies uh they didn't want
him to run in 2016. they didn't endorse
him initially in 2020.
uh that they knew that he they didn't
want their image sullied quite frankly
and they didn't want to hitch their
wagon to this
again disaster
so they are he is completely incompetent
and we have seen this all along but this
is a
shell sold to us
uh by the media who lied about trump for
four years
greg gutfeld well i mean thank god they
hid hunter biden's laptop
that that's led to this uh what did we
learn from the president uh we learned
today that ron desantis is worse than
the taliban that's what he believes he
needs
president biden the democratic party
desperately need a country to be scared
of kovid or they're going to lose the
grip on the presidency and they're going
to lose their power because they're in
huge trouble right now and he's in he's
he might be a mortally wounded president
from this so given this massive breaking
news this came off as a wholly desperate
uh tactic it's almost like during the
rise of a pandemic deciding you're going
to initiate an impeachment against trump
or during a crime epidemic or a crime a
wave you focus on white supremacy it's
all for it's all about distracting i am
relieved though that the un
issued a strongly
worded letter to the taliban
uh i know that's something that the
taliban would respect i would have
wished a singing telegram or a stripper
gram but it does reveal
how arrogant
and idiotic these people are i'm trying
to remember who i talked to yesterday
but they say when you go higher and
higher into power you realize
everything's like high school that was
me was that you yes yes and everything
you find out that the people that you
expect to be really smart and capable
are just the same jackasses as you saw
in homeroom because
for the u.n to send that letter they
have to actually
believe that they can have an impact as
though like when you're in the media do
you think that you can affect britney
spears conservatorship if we do that
story often enough they might change
we're we have to get out of this mindset
that somehow we can dismantle the
patriarchy in a place where they'll
behead you over clothing
so that's the u.n uh none of the gender
studies classes that you were teaching
in kabul helped sorry
what a waste of money yeah can i just
give you one little thing 15 seconds
uh
general milly saying it to choose
between the embassy and bagram bagram
had to go
you see how they mustered that force at
that airport how the 82nd airborne which
i have been with in combat they they're
like that they had uh marine
expeditionary forces they had the
british special forces
couldn't you just see why didn't they go
to bagram right with that they were in
position
hold backroom hold a place that's
defensible not not the alamo yeah they
said it was a tactical decision that was
recommended to them by the commander on
the ground in afghanistan through that
guy right under the bus
up next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else